I remain hopeful though I will most
certainly not have rest until I have my
husband safely with me if I hadn't him
to come to Britain on the
Kindertransport it's unlikely I'd have
survived the Holocaust so let's save my
life and make the camera Audrey between
a girl you can never say no in these
things there are certain people want
return destiny I think George's Dux
without the Georgian anyway shocked over
a British academic jailed for life for
allegedly spying in the United Arab
Emirates PhD student Matthew hedges was
arrested in May accused of working on
behalf of the UK government the Gulf
states foreign ministry has said it
wants to reach an amicable conclusion
after sharp criticism from the Foreign
Secretary Jeremy Hunt er said he'll do
everything in his power to free Matthew
hedges I try not to think too much about
it because it's quite possibly the
hardest five minutes of my life
seeing him shaking and seeing him asked
his translator whether he had actually
said life in prison was as heartbreaking
as it gets he
I could see that he couldn't conceive
what was going on and of course not
being even able to say goodbye it was
just yeah it was the hardest time of my
life and I think I've been through a lot
of hard things but this is necessarily
the worst of them all I hope that they
will see it in their hearts that this is
a good man with incredible good nature
that deserves to be free but I am
disappointed at the fact that the UAE
insists that there has been due process
where it evidently failed after six
months of solitary confinement with no
access to legal counsel and very limited
access to consular visits but again I
remain hopeful though I will most
certainly not have rest until I have my
husband safely with me Foreign Secretary
Jeremy Hunt is already battling to free
a British woman as a ninja Gary
Ratcliffe in Iran mrs. o'deary Ratliff's
husband has told Sky News his wife is
hanging on hopes of what Jeremy hunts a
visitor could achieve I've been really
pleased with that with her strident the
first option has been it's been really
clear that you know it hasn't even
shouldn't be in prison that she should
be released and that it's unacceptable
to be holding British citizens as
leverage on diplomatic issues and we
wait a long time for someone British
government to say that clearly I'm
really pleased he had she's definitely
in a place where this has gone on long
enough
I said to his staff I've said to him I
think when I when I know Nanshan space
now we're just gonna be really
straightforward and she's near the end
of their tether and that's trying to
finish this thing
[Music]
now at 7:30 three in the evening on the
21st of November 1938 so eighty years
ago a debate began in Parliament that
was to result in thousands of lives
being saved it led to the creation of
the Kindertransport evacuation of around
10,000 children predominantly Jewish
from Nazi Germany to Britain in the
final months before the second world war
minister after dams and lord ups was
akin to transport refugee himself and
was also behind the Dubs amendment of
the 2016 pledge the government has now
abandoned to take in 3,000 vulnerable
and unaccompanied child refugees from
across Europe asked him his thoughts on
the Kindertransport scheme which
probably saved his life well it was a
very important occasion clearly if I
hadn't been able to come to Britain on a
kinder transport it's unlikely I'd have
survived the Holocaust so that saved my
life
and looking back upon it it was a
momentous occasion what Britain did
other countries didn't do it Britain was
pretty well the only country that said
we'll take these children from the
clutches of the Nazis and we lived here
you know and we had great lives here
more about your circumstances though or
Dubbs I mean it was it was children in
it there weren't any adults that's
obviously it in the name they're your
personals well my father was Jewish my
mother wasn't and my father said if the
Nazis come to Prague he will leave
immediately
he said to his cousins that was his plan
the cousin said we'll take our chance
and they they were taken to Auschwitz in
1942 my father left my mother was a fuse
permission to leave so she got me on a
kinder transport before that I remember
quite vividly in the front page of my
school book I had a picture of President
Bennish the Czech president had to tear
that out and stick in a picture of
Hitler and that's stuck with me in my
country my school but my one school book
anyway so my mother put me on him on a
Kindertransport I can still in my mind's
eye see her standing at the station with
a friend German soldiers of swastikas
and background I was six I was one of
the youngest and the taint took a couple
of days to get to what to get to
Liverpool Street via the ferry from the
Hook of Holland to her
astonishing memories and all kinds of
stories of course coming out at the
moment including this one Julie you've
been aware about it for a long time but
Clement Attlee later also later to
become
labour Prime Minister took in yeah
himself took in a child who has been a
mother and a child I think yes fantastic
story what what a sign of of how that
man could do something for his fellow
human beings he didn't have to do it and
he did it that's great it's a good story
it's a lesson to us all and you and I
have talked over the years the last few
years about those lessons particularly
when it comes to child refugee very very
different conflicts but unfortunately no
shortage of child refugees and the
British attitude now we've talked in the
past about Britain taking in up to a
similar number 10,000 children has it
happened has anything changed well we've
taken a few not as many as I would have
wished or as I think Parliament believed
at the time of passing and the amendment
of the Immigration Act the government
put a cap on it anyway cap on the
numbers are too arbitrary so the numbers
are small and the need is desperate I've
been to refugee camps in in northern
France
well the camps the jungles gone I've
been to camps in Greece I've been to
Jordan and indeed the situation on the
Greek islands is pretty awful for young
people it's dangerous they're vulnerable
to sexual abuse and they're there and a
very little hope and to my mind the most
important thing is hope you can put up
with bad conditions if there is hope
there but where there's no hope it's
very hard to continue functioning
probably
[Music]
it was a crime that shocked Britain
two-year-old James Bolger was tortured
and killed by ten-year-old schoolboys
the youngest killers in more than 250
years the toddler was snatched from a
shopping centre in Merseyside on the
12th of February 1993 by Robert Thompson
and Jon Venables now a short film about
the harrowing events and the boy's
imprisonment has been released based on
real-life interview transcripts writer
in director Vincent Lam told me why he
decided to look at the case I grew up
hearing about it I can never understand
how these two boys could commit such a
horrific crime and it was years and
years later as an adult I I just I
wanted to know I wanted to know how it
happened I started reading everything I
could find on it and I then I I felt
like I was seeing something that not
everyone was seeing with that case at
the same time I had you know a lot of
apprehensions about making this case
because it's so sensitive and and people
still feel so strongly about it so I
when I decided to adopt the interviews
as a 30 minute drama I wanted to make
sure it was entirely factual and that
there was no embellishments in there
whatsoever tell us about the
apprehensions I mean what were your main
concerns so Wow I mean people in the UK
it's it's it's something that just
divides public opinion and the public
outrage at the time was unprecedented
and it hasn't really gone away I found
it still causes outrage today and it's I
think at the time I I can understand
white people you know think of those
boys as evil and and and I grew up
always thinking that but I I just I
always thought it was easier to call
them evil than to really look into it
and to try to understand why that
happened and I think if you look into
their family backgrounds it doesn't
explain everything but it'll it will
kind of give you a little bit more
insight into the how and
why it could have happened is there's
nothing new in the film I think every
it's the the facts of being there the
transcripts have been there but it's
just a different way of looking at them
it's a changed by the hand and let
amounted Australian shots we never we
never no not we
Robert is saying that you took him by
the hand we never not Robert you did it
I love it well why would Robert say that
about I don't think John did everything
yeah well I never I think you is it lost
what you think there's only one person
here that knows the old truth I know and
I've just said it all painful to watch
isn't it what was it like to be the
director going through those transcripts
well they were hugely emotional I mean
which is what I I was surprised that
when when I started looking into it I
thought it's it wasn't what I expected
to find you know and then I kind of
realized that there was this human story
beneath it from the research I saw I
mean the interviews were full of emotion
I mean you see John there where he's
he's up out of his chair he's hysterical
at one point he throws himself in the
lap of the detectives for comfort and I
think it's a it's a story that that just
made me look at it from another angle
but at the same time I'm I've enormous
sympathy for the family of James Bulger
and but I Ito James his family I I
didn't you know and and I think this
would probably be you know a painful
watch for them because the film you know
well it's it's not meant to be
sympathetic to the boys in any way it's
not meant to make excuses but it was
humanized them and I think what the film
does it kind of it looks at you know the
the worst of human potential and what
still sees humanity there
[Music]
remember this it's 1994 and Sky News is
visiting London's first internet cafe
the world wide web is growing fast
spreading the new lines of communication
and giving anyone anywhere a chance to
have their say it allows anyone them to
publish that information and 30 million
people can read it that 30 million now
an estimated 3.2 billion and that
freedom to publish and read and build
what you like has come with consequences
its creator
- Tim berners-lee says it's time for a
rethink it used not to worry me because
I felt the my duty as a web user was
just to go and find the stuff which I
appreciated which I trusted but now I I
think everybody involved in the web
realize is that the problem is that
other people to go out there other
people are reading stuff which is
complete garbage and they're believing
it and they've looked you talk to anyone
in street now and about the web and
they're not necessarily happy this fake
news that people being manipulated on
social networks to vote in particular
ways and so on and the one thing after
another or people be concerned about
their privacy I think there are lots of
reasons why we have to step back and say
think well keeping it open and free was
is important but doesn't necessarily
mean that all the things that happen it
will be walk in a constant march towards
Bennis eyes at the knowledge and better
democracy
[Music]
some people look forward to the release
of the John Lewis Christmas adverse
month one man it does spell some trouble
yes each year John Lewis a computer
science lecturer from the United States
gets inundated with messages on social
media about the ad campaign ads about
things like returns it's a very modern
story there's his own battle to keep up
with them all has now inspired Twitter
to make him the star of his own
Christmas in Richmond initially yeah it
was just a kind of a Larkin and then it
really snowballed into something much
bigger and the the number of tweets
increased and you know the more I had
fun with it the more I was able to to
make it bearable and it just went from
there they get in touch at least once a
year usually around this time just kind
of thanking me for pointing them in the
right direction for for certain tweets
and yeah and over the years they've
they've actually sent me some nice some
nice kind of Christmastime presents and
it's been a very nice relationship the
folks from Twitter UK got in touch and
said they had this idea and we talked
about it a little bit and then just move
forward and people are asking me now is
that really your house and and really
your study and and it is they sent a
crew over from the UK here to do the
whole filming and it was a you know a
big whirlwind of a day that you know
eventually got broke it down into one
minute of video so I appreciate a lot
more the effort that goes into these
kind of things
[Music]
cartoonist zoom Rahman was just 12 years
old when his work was first published in
the been--all and at 16 he became the
youngest cartoonist in privatized and
magazine history now 18 he's drawn most
waddled leaders past and present
capturing the lighter side to conduct
I've been drawing ever since I could
hold up a pen when I was around the age
of 8 my family went to a copy fair and
we found a box full of old Beano comics
and I'd never actually seen a comic
before so I've been drawing for as long
as I could remember and I'd like to make
up funny stories in my head but I didn't
know that you could put the two together
in this medium and so my parents bought
them and over the next few days I was
reading them in my beds my dad kept
having to come into my room and tell me
to go to sleep and then I started
drawing Dennis the Menace watch the
Dodger and then I decided that I can
forego doing my own characters and then
eventually when I produce pages and
pages of comic stories I had enough to
put them all together into my own comic
and at 16 he became the youngest
published cartoonist in private eyes
history now I know for a fact there is a
very competitive process to get cartoons
into private eye in fact to get them
anywhere these days so how did that come
about so basically I've been doing the
Beano for four years and I noticed that
some of the cartoons that I was
submitting were a bit too old for their
audience and so I was thinking of new
places to go to and I'd been watching
have I got news for you for quite a
while
and so I knew in I knew about in his
lock-on I knew about Private Eye and I'm
also interested in Peter Cook he used to
edit by and so one of my latest comics
was based on a Peter Cook and Dudley
Moore sketch called what's the worst
bloody thing that could happen to you
yeah and other one and so I sent that to
in his lock with a covering letter
saying how do I get into Private Eye and
then he just sent me a letter back
giving all the details and it kind of
just went on from there all done
and you've had some quite powerful
cartoons in private I have a new one
that stands out for me as Big Ben in the
house of the parliament covered in the
cladding in the wake of the groennfell
tower and tragedy you've now got this
exhibition at Simpsons in the Strand
your artist-in-residence
there with your Winston Churchill
illustrations yesterday I was saying you
had a press breakfast there to launch
your exhibition and then he headed
straight off to college and back to
reality thing today
yep so you're here and then you're off
to college and you're doing an outfit
foundation yeah st. Martin's what your
contemporaries think of your celebrity
status it's just a bit surreal and a bit
embarrassing for me actually modest
to be yeah I was gonna say get used to
it
[Applause]
[Music]
I miss the camaraderie between those
girls and like being with other people
every day is the lovely like it's
different being on your own but like now
I obviously see the other girls in a
different capacity like Cheryl's little
boy bear he's the same age as my
youngest Cole which is just good
planning or look we didn't plan it out
today but it really works out really
well and so now we're gonna see each
other in that faster in the plane and we
never finished a conversation or a cup
of tea anymore but and we still see each
other but we're in a sort of new phase
of our lives which I like actually you
can never say never with these things
because I'm sure at one time the Spice
Girls would have been like no challenge
and now it's like it just feels like the
right time for them to to reunite and we
haven't actually been apart that long I
think it's it's the generation of people
reuniting but we've actually not being
apart that long so I feel like maybe we
need a few more years for people to
actually care whether we come back he's
in his 80s and is arguably still one of
the greatest chat show hosts to grace
the UK's television screens but recently
some Michael Parkinson has turned his
attention to writing a memoir about his
friend George best and in his new book
so Michael recounts the highs and many
lows of the footballers life through a
friend's eyes behaviour of [ __ ] so
the boy who arrived the shy kid was not
a thing like the boy was in two years
time he's very confident young teenager
who understood where it was in the
hierarchy of things they went George
first arrived in there cuz he went
straight back home ago no he's been
overawed by dogs in those days made his
Manchester United his Matt Busby because
all that is Bobby Charlton you know and
it was awesome for a kid from from from
the this state in the Kreger name in
Belfast
you could play but it wasn't happy in
that situation but then wake bag already
came back later on I was convinced I
became convinced that he fitted he could
see exactly where we fit into this
entire scenario then well stand by
course I mean that's when he first
started become the great player that he
is or was I think there are certain
people born to account destiny I think
George was that was going to happen to
George in any event there was something
with him
that was irresistible this is a drink
vessel I suppose he never regarded his
life is being tragedy you know that was
a thing about him didn't mean oh no no I
mean people do have tragic don't use
that word to me tragic you know I've
done this myself nobody else me I've
done that and I've enjoyed it thanks pal
good night that was George you see and
he never he was the most wrong
complaining man I've ever met he he
never ever tried to blame other people
for his predicament and I found that
totally admirable those are most
admirable trait I think he had I mean
did you ever as a friend take him aside
and say George is there anything more I
can do for you you need I think we all
tried I had a problem because I Ramon
bring problems wrong return death of my
father I hit the bottle rather hard and
sometimes with George so he saw me an
extremist and I wasn't the guy to let
shame about me not only behaved or
whatever on the other hand when I mean I
didn't have an illness I wasn't there I
was just drinking stupidly and I stopped
and that was fine from that point on
well I enjoyed didn't stop and that was
the difference but no I I never wanted
to be in the situation I think how we
dealt with is very strange I know and it
was Mary pointed out to me he said
you've stopped seeing a lot of George
and I hadn't realized that what you're
saying was true and then I thought yeah
it's been a wild I thought we're
avoiding each other he didn't want me to
see him in extremis I didn't want to see
him drunk out of his mind of falling
down and so that was partly the reason
behind the book that I felt unfinished
business and I thought I didn't go to
the funeral I've loved loved have spoken
at the funeral and all that and I didn't
and so the book the book is basically
sir it's an epistle to a mate
yeah to all the good times we had
together and to the memories of we had
and also to the greatest player I ever
saw
you
[Music]